Let's go next to our caller.
Oh, we've got someone from the 4 1 3 area
code who's calling today from 4 1 3.
Hey, let me.
Yes, it is.
Who's this?
Oh, this is Tyler.
I'm originally from Belltown, Massachusetts,
but I live in Washington, D.C. now.
It is cool.
What's going on?
I'm starting to hear a lot of talk about how
the government is going to use the crisis
in order to curtail personal freedoms.
Sort of like how the Patriot Act was used.
And I don't know if I'm just naive, but I'm
not super concerned about that and just wondering
what your opinion on it is.
So I think that here's the here's the.
So there's some truth to it, but it's not
really in the way that most people fear.
So the way most people fear the government
using the corona virus crisis to curtail freedoms
are the kind of dystopian sci fi, you know,
ways of monitoring people in ways that that
that exceed what the current law allows.
Or, you know, people are talking about martial
law, military in the streets and all this
type of stuff.
What they're doing, they're already doing,
which is, for example, court systems are not
functioning at full capacity.
So one of the things that the Trump administration
is now asking for is that habeas corpus, which
basically allow, determines or dictates people
can't just be held indefinitely without being
charged or tried.
Right.
You got it.
There has to be a process that continues moving
forward reasonably quickly.
The idea is, hey, listen.
Courts can't really process as much as they
can normally because of the virus.
So we should sort of just like allow people
to be indefinitely detained, even if we can't
give them a trial anytime soon.
That's being done like that.
It's happening now.
So it is happening.
It's just probably not in the exact way that
some people are fearful of.
Yeah.
I mean, I think we definitely have to be mindful
of that.
But I'm hearing some people using that as
an excuse as to why we shouldn't take this
seriously and why we shouldn't tax more.
Right.
No, it's.
The solution is that's not the solution.
The solution would be, listen, if the justice
system can't process people, then you're going
to have to just like let some people go and
then, you know, you're not you're going to
have to maybe re apprehend them later.
And some people are gonna be flight risks
and you won't be able to.
But it's incumbent upon the justice system
to provide that speedy trial.
And you can't say, well, you just sit in jail
indefinitely.
So I think you're right that there are people
who are cynically coming up with the wrong
solution to this problem.
But we want to make sure that it doesn't get
misused to minimize how much we should all
just be staying the hell home.
Absolutely.
Well, hey, thanks for answering my call.
Have a great day.
All right, Tyler, great to hear from you.
I appreciate it.